what i'm excited for fans to see in
season two is is the relationship
that forms between chris and selena i'm
excited for them to see the love story
you get to see more concerts you get to
see more of the music
relationships
[Music]
hi christian congratulations you are
fantastic in this role
um i'm curious if you had an opportunity
beyond you know studying music videos
and interviews on the internet did you
have a chance
to actually go spend some time with the
quintanillas and learn more about you
know selena off camera
i went straight from atlanta to mexico
and just dove straight into work and was
so
grateful for the the internet
i had great resources i relied so
heavily on like selena fan pages and
youtube
and luckily we had her family on board
because it gave us i think more of an
intimate understanding
of her and the hard work that came
before
her becoming the legend that we know
today you know our first season
focuses so much on her upbringing and
her
family and what a family girl she was
and how important that was to her and
what a hard-working mexican-american
family they were it was really exciting
for me to see that she didn't always
look the way i thought she looked like
it's a coming-of-age story and you're
seeing her
find herself as an artist and change her
look and her hair and
i don't think a lot of fans really know
that about her all i wanted was a song
good enough
so write a song
playing a b and playing abraham um did
either of you get a chance to spend time
with a b and abraham to really capture
their essence
no i i did i did not uh you know we've
we've had contact with uh quintanilla
who's an exact producer
on the show but um in terms of contact
with
with abraham myself no i i did not did
you not want to or was it not made
available to you
um at the time it wasn't it wasn't made
available i think there was some talk
that we were trying to do it but
you know once once we got into the thick
of things and and started
shooting uh i for me personally i
i didn't i'm i'm glad that i didn't have
the contact
because uh i was able to just kind of
sit in this what i was doing and how i
was approaching this role without having
any kind of outside interference
okay gabrielle how about you uh same
same definitely the same
pretty much to what we got of the set um
but i do think the quintanilla family
you know i think they understood
that you know it's a tv show it's a
different process so
um and i'm sure that they're very very
respectful of it uh we did we did get a
chance to to
to chat with uh suzette quintanilla and
that was great you
really need a different drummer there's
no beatles without ringo
and there's no selena without susan
unfortunately we i didn't have a chance
to
um to meet marcella and interact with
marcela
what i did was i looked through footage
and there's very little footage but i
did find
one video where they asked her
about being a mom and it was in spanish
but the
way that she answered that question
said so much for me that i use that as
my foundation to build on
and i said okay this this woman is
nurturing she's caring she's loving but
she's also strong when she needs to be
we were given the opportunity to create
our characters objectively
the family suzette specifically provided
some
materials that aren't available to the
public for us to really really
deep dive and shape our characters and
sadie
uh christian and myself we met suzette
um the last two weeks of filming so we
disconnected
as women as now musicians and
artists and and just you know all things
selena and the legacy and it was a
really beautiful beautiful moment
come on i ain't got nothing to wear then
we're just gonna have to go
shopping duh sadie you have
quite a beautiful full circle story here
you were right there with jennifer lopez
side by side in the original movie
and here you are now you're side by side
with christian cerratos
um i'm curious what is your take on on
how
jennifer portrayed selena versus what
you experienced with christian's
interpretation
it's different experiences when jennifer
worked on the film
selena had just passed and so
a lot of people were just getting to
know who selena was
and so she had full-on
um connection to the family
they coached her they she even lived
there for a little bit
so so jennifer had that advantage and
she had
you know that um and she has
also that beautiful essence and that
beautiful
um fire you know what i mean she just
had that naturally
and on the other hand with christian is
she has she has this tenderness
naturally that it was very much needed
for our story
because we we do tell a lot of
the behind the scenes as well and we
also tell a lot of her childhood and her
teen years
and what it took to develop that star
and that
big icon that we know now and so i think
that they were both
perfect casting for the time
selena to selena did you and jennifer
have a chance to connect
no um but i would love to thank her
because i'm a huge
fan of the work that she did on the film
and i thought she did an incredible job
so hopefully one day
for you as an actress what was the one
moment performance
look the one thing that you were like i
cannot
mess this up i've gotta crush it every
moment
i'm happy that every one of those
moments felt like that
important to me because it made me
really
work 10 times harder and i wanted to
work
so hard to make the fans happy and her
family happy and to honor her legacy
so there wasn't really a day that went
where that went by that i didn't think
this is your day you
you nailed this or or or you've ruined
the whole thing
there was some a lot more care that went
into
the performances um you know and to make
sure that
things that we were emulating precisely
like her acceptance speeches and things
were accurate um
because you know her stage presence is
very uniquely selena and people know her
for the
for those performances and they are
going to be looking at those details and
i think we really
all paid such close attention to detail
of course
christian as our selena what was your
reaction the first time you saw her
in hair makeup and wardrobe when we did
the astrodome performance
wow like you know super super surreal
um and she's great you know christian's
amazing she does an amazing job
uh especially when she's performing when
she's out there dancing and singing
are you guys ready to stop
season one ends perfectly set up for
season two
have you started filming part two and
what are you most excited for the fans
to see
everything is is is done and i'm so
excited for the fans to see everything
i'm excited for them to see
the library of music that she had
because it really surprised me i thought
i knew every selena song
and there are so many more songs that i
want to become
as mainstream as songs like homo la flor
um
but i'm excited for them to see this
hard-working mexican-american family
this
this girl who was so smart and so
business savvy
and i'm excited for them to see the love
story
i think the work that jesse did was so
good what was the secret to you and
jesse
coming together and really giving the
the love and importance that that love
story deserves a lot of communication
jessie and i got on so well and
he's such an incredible actor and so
honest and so charming like people are
just gonna fall in love and gush over
jesse
him and i worked a lot with each other
and had to be very vulnerable with each
other and
trust each other and i trust jesse so
much and really just can't wait for
people
to see his work what i'm excited for
fans to see in season two
is is the relationship that forms
between
uh chris and selena and how
they start to manage becoming young
adults in a relationship
oh my gosh scale of one to ten i mean
are we gonna be in our fields
is it dramatic is it emotional it's it's
it's all the above yeah that's depend on
every every emotional level
you get to see more concerts you get to
see more of the music
um you get the
sadie as marcella abraham um
as adults in part one now you really get
to see these children grow up as adults
and how they navigate the world as
adults so it's really nice to see that
with
all things in mind already of the
history we know so it's really fun to
see
the characters we fell in love with in a
new segment of their life
you